hey everyone chef joe sasso here i'm
back you guys asked for it today we're
diving into the world of smash burgers
but not just any smash burgers
my recipe for smash burgers
[Music]
all right so i like onions with my
smashed burgers we're going to do some
quick caramelized onions here none of
that low and slow business
we don't got time for that today
so hot pan
a little bit of oil
and then our onions
[Music]
we're not going to go low and slow here
we don't want to develop any of those
sugars or really break them down i want
them to have a little bit of texture
some salt and pepper
and we're just getting color on the
outside
and cooking them through so we're not
biting down into raw onions take that
off the heat we'll set this aside
now let's talk secret spread after this
movie much of a secret but that's okay i
like you guys my favorite part of the
spread is of course the pickles chili
paste some black garlic or
ketchup mayo and mustard if you like
things a little more ketchupy
add more ketchup
then of course a little salt
some black pepper
you know i always like sugar to balance
everything out
getting started on our patty here i have
a little bit of ground beef left in my
freezer but i also have this really
awesome dry edge ribeye i've been
working on i'm going to grind this in my
meat grinder and mix it with some ground
beef that i have
now we're just going to season this up
of course you could just go salt and
pepper here you get crazy add whatever
you'd like
but i just like to pre-season all the
patties so it's even and distributed
throughout the burgers
to shape my burgers
this does not have to be as precise i'm
just going to kind of come in here and
divide out the meat
now i am leaving these
in large rounds because
we're going to smash them
in the pan
[Music]
all right the moments here we're ready
to cook our burgers a little bit of oil
down in the pan
and you should hear those start to
sizzle immediately when you put the
burgers in and we don't want to touch
these we're going to leave them get a
nice caramelized crispy bottom before we
smash them down now the beauty of a
smash burger is actually getting to
smash it
so now
time to come in here
flip our burgers
you see we have a golden brown
caramelized exterior and now for the
smash
[Music]
we're going for a thin patty here
these are all going to be well done but
that's okay
because it's not a thick burger it's a
thin burger
and so well done is what we want here
i'm going to pull these out while i cook
the rest of the burgers before we
assemble
i really like this recipe because it
lets you do all the different components
before bringing it back together and
turning these smash burgers into steam
buns
start with a little bit of our spread i
like some on the top and bottom
now we're gonna bring on our patties
now you go single but for me
i'm gonna do a double
i like to put the onions before the last
slice of cheese that way cheese acts as
a little barrier to hold them all in
place then we got our lids
this is not the final step one more
thing to do all right burgers are
assembled time for the finishing move i
still have my hot pan here with all the
beef drippings we're going to gently
place each of the burgers
back into the bottom of the pan
tiny bit of water here and we're going
to create steam and put the lid on
quickly
[Music]
i can't wait to try this i think i'm
just gonna go for one should i i should
yes okay let's do it we got the double
patty sliced american cheese i wouldn't
have it any other way
[Music]
so good
that's everything i want in a burger
double patty extra thin crispy
melty cheese caramelized onions that
spread forget about it you gotta try
these thank you all for joining me i
hope you enjoyed this as much as i did
check out this and some of my other
recipes on buzzfeed tasty follow me
along on instagram chef.joe.sasco
for more of my at-home cooking
adventures peace out everybody
see you next time
oh yes
[Music]
you